[Música]
ah
nuestro presente es fantástico
para venir al anfiteatro de cargamos no
hasta el auto el motor la usa desaparece
y en pocos minutos estamos acá tenemos
sed
tomamos una bebida de una botella
plástica práctica liviana la terminamos
la tiramos y desaparece
inclusive podemos usar un sorbete
que es cómodo higiénico y de un único
uso también lo tiramos y desaparece
todo esto definitivamente fantástico
porque en parte es una fantasía
ni la botella ni el sorbete
desaparecieron seguramente se van a
acumular en algún basural o pero aún
para terminar en el río o en el mar
el motor no hizo desaparecer la nafta
sino que la transformó en distintos
gases algunos con efecto invernadero
el desafío que tenemos hoy al
desarrollar nuevas tecnologías es
conservar las comodidades de nuestro
estilo de vida pero sin afectar al medio
ambiente en forma sustentable
los plásticos derivados del petróleo son
livianos duraderos económicos y por eso
han revolucionado en nuestro estilo de
vida
su masiva producción en las últimas
décadas que alcanza el orden de los 350
millones de toneladas por año ha llevado
a su acumulación en todos los nichos
especialmente el acuático afectando a la
fauna de todo el planeta
un avance es el reciclado de los
plásticos pero esto es laborioso no es
tan económico y cada tipo de plástico se
tiene que recuperar por separado menos
del 10% de los plásticos que se
descartan se reciclan
otro avance superador es el del ovillo
desde los bioplásticos
en lugar de provenir del petróleo se
originan principalmente en el almidón y
el azúcar de las plantas entonces son
sustentables renovables pero muchos de
ellos no son biodegradables menos del 1
por ciento de los de los plásticos que
se producen son bio plásticos
principalmente por su costo
con respecto a los combustibles fósiles
como el carbón el gas y el petróleo
han permitido el transporte la
generación de electricidad la
industrialización son nuestra principal
fuente de energía
pero con los años nos hemos dado cuenta
que esta combustión continua está
generando gases de efecto invernadero
está causando polución en los grandes
centros poblados y otros problemas de
salud
un avances significativos es el de los
biocombustibles que en lugar de
obtenerse de las profundidades de son
reservas en las profundidades del
planeta se generan a partir de vegetales
a partir del dióxido de carbono del aire
y de la energía solar podemos cultivar
oleaginosas como la soja de las cuales
obtenemos aceite o maíz y caña a partir
de los cuales se obtienen almidón y
azúcar en un proceso industrial a partir
de las del aceite de la soja podemos
obtener biodiesel
se puede utilizar justamente en los
motores diésel y a partir de el almidón
y el azúcar podemos obtener bio alcohol
que se puede mezclar con las naftas
comunes
esto es muy bueno son soluciones
sustentables y renovables pero con el
aumento de escala porque se están
utilizando mucho se están empezando a
acumular algunos residuos o subproductos
de la industria del biodiesel se genera
glicerina cruda por cada tonelada de
aceite que se utiliza para generar
biodiesel se acumulan 100 kilogramos de
esta glicerina cruda que está
contaminada con metanol sales y algunos
compuestos orgánicos todo esto dificulta
su uso posterior
y de la industria del alcohol se generan
vinazas por cada litro de alcohol que se
produce se generan cinco o más litros de
vinaza en el caso de caña está vinaza se
utiliza para regar y fertilizar los
campos pero como tiene un alto contenido
salino sólo una pequeña fracción se
puede usar y el resto hay que tirarlo
con el impacto ambiental que tiene
como ven
todos los avances y todas estas
soluciones son parciales
para realmente alcanzar lo que estamos
buscando necesitamos un nuevo paradigma
que es la bioeconomía o economía
circular en qué consiste esto en
aprovechar los residuos o subproductos
de algún proceso como punto de partida o
materia prima para otro proceso que los
aproveche y a eso nos dedicamos en una
empresa que hemos fundado dos
investigadores del conicet junto con un
grupo inversor en biotecnología lo que
les voy a mostrar es un desarrollo que
atacan los dos problemas que les estuve
contando la acumulación de los residuos
de la industria de los combustibles de
segunda generación y el tema de los
plásticos que no se pueden reciclar
lo que hemos hecho es generar bacterias
que se alimentan de estos residuos de la
vinaza y de la glicemia cruda y los
transforman en un bioplástico este
material se llama ph o poli hidroxi
alcano hato y es 100% biodegradable
tanto en tierra como en un río o en el
mar
sus propiedades se parecen a las del
polipropileno que es parte de las
botellas plásticas típicas
como hicimos esto en la naturaleza hay
bacterias que producen ph como su forma
de reserva pero solo haz lo hacen en
ciertas condiciones y en forma poco
eficiente entonces de esas bacterias
extrajimos su adn de información
genética
dentro de hacer adn seleccionamos los
genes con las instrucciones para
fabricar ph y esos genes se los pusimos
a otra bacteria que es de uso industrial
o sea que crece rápido y en forma
eficiente
a esa bacteria también la optimizamos
para que no haga otros subproductos que
habitualmente hace por ejemplo ácido
acético ácido láctico y le eliminamos
las instrucciones para hacer esos
productos
de esta forma hemos obtenido una
bacteria que acumula más del 75 por
ciento de su peso en plástico que es lo
blanco que se ve en el interior de las
bacterias en esta micro fotografía que
está señalado por la flecha
como llevamos adelante esto hemos
montado plataformas tecnológicas para
editar el genoma de las bacterias o sea
agregarle o quitarle instrucciones para
que trabajen
para cultivarlas o sea multiplicar las
en condiciones similares a las
industriales para ir ya pensando en
escalar un proyecto y principalmente
medimos todos los productos que generan
y todos los metabolitos que sintetizan
para que para saber si le falta algo
para trabajar mejor para producir
plástico o si está produciendo
compuestos que no nos interesan con esa
información volvemos a editar el genoma
de la bacteria para agregar o quitar
instrucciones este ciclo lo repetimos
hasta que maximizamos la producción de
bioplásticos y una vez que alcanzamos
ese punto procedemos a purificar y
escalar los procesos
en este momento tenemos un proceso que
ya alcanzó un punto de industrialización
y ahora nos estamos dedicando a generar
aplicaciones y el mercado para estos
bioplásticos
como son más costosos que los plásticos
derivados del petróleo estamos apuntando
a dos tipos de soluciones aquellas en
las que las normas impidan el uso de
materiales que no sean biodegradables o
aquellas en que el hecho de que el
plástico sea biodegradable implica un
haber o un ahorro extra para el que lo
utiliza
en el primer caso tenemos por ejemplo
los sorbetes que hoy en día están
prohibidos en muchas ciudades
especialmente las costeras porque son
plásticos de un único uso y que tiene
mucho impacto ambiental
si el plástico está hecho de un material
biodegradable si se puede utilizar
y el hecho de que se utilice o que venga
en una gaseosa en un combo que es algo
muy costoso implica que unos pocos
centavos que uno le agregue al sorbete
no tiene un efecto sobre el precio del
combo que uno está comprando porque
recargo
recalco la parte económica porque para
que esta tecnología como cualquier otra
se implemente tiene que ser rentable y
tiene que justificar la inversión de
aquel que decide apostar a esta
tecnología que la va a poder recuperar
al otro que estamos apuntando
es a los envases de insumos
agropecuarios como los herbicidas
hoy las normas obligan a que cada uno de
estos envases tenga que ser lavado tres
veces y devuelto a origen esto es
laborioso e implica camiones
transportando plástico vacío con el
impacto y el costo que tiene sobre el
ambiente
si el bidón está hecho de un material
biodegradable se puede enterrar
directamente en el campo y en pocos
meses no queda nada ahorrándose el
lavado y el transporte ese ahorro para
el productor agropecuario justifica que
el envase valga un poco más que el que
viene de plástico derivado del petróleo
para que todas estas soluciones se
implementen no alcanza solamente con
investigadores emprendedores e
inversores hacen falta políticas
públicas definidas que estimulen el
desarrollo y la adopción de estas
tecnologías
de nuestra parte estamos más que
ansiosos porque esta capacidad que
tenemos de transformar residuos
agroindustriales en materiales amigables
con el medio ambiente se industrializa
lo antes posible
de esa forma vamos a pasar a vivir en un
mundo fantástico y sustentable
donde este sorbete que si es 100%
biodegradable se pueda tirar y
desaparecer muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]